big fan he's a canadian i love his music  he has me blocked on instagram no idea  why what but you can find out what has  you blocked  especially  i don't know maybe i'm a big fan i  [ __ ] love justin bieber also you may  ever slander him in something no i think  it's because i used to roll or i used to  make fun of uh like lele pons a lot  that's what i'm saying like when i was  25 right i was like making videos  earlier lately one of them is just  called lele pons is bad  and she  his like one of his like managers or  whatever it managed her as well and i  think they just like really didn't like  me right and uh so you know if you're  watching  unblock him maybe you got a uh lele pons  apology video in the works you know  maybe  buy your way back and the real just a  real like the the real like intention is  to get justin bieber unblock me